Jeans are easily one of the most ubiquitous
pieces of clothing on Earth with millions
of pairs being made, sold and wrapped around
the butts of style conscious individuals every
single day.
But why are jeans so popular and for what
purpose were they first made?
Before we answer that it’s important for
us to first define exactly what we mean when
we say “jeans” because the word has changed
in context over the last few hundred years.
As detailed by the Fashion Enyclopedia, the
term “jeans” has existed since the 1600s,
where it was used as a catch-all term to describe
the “rough clothing worn by working men”.
Since the fabric used to make these clothes
often came from the Genoa region in Italy,
it was commonly referred to as “jean”.
Weavers from the Nimes area of France tried
to replicate this fabric and it eventually
came to be known as “denim” a bastardization
of the words “de Nimes” (from Nimes).
Cool, huh?
So what makes modern jeans so different from
the work trousers found on the legs of 16th
century workers?
Well, the key difference is in how modern
jeans are held together, rivets.
If you’re currently wearing a pair of jeans,
which is statistically quite likely, you may
notice that they are held together at key
points with small rivets.
(You may also notice that your zipper has
the letters “YKK” on it and if you’re
interested in why, we covered that in another
article).
These rivets are a relatively new addition
to jeans and they’re the reason for the
garments legendary longevity.
Contrary to what you may have thought, unlike
the stitch pattern often found on the rear
pockets, the rivets aren’t just for show,
they’re strategically placed at the locations
the garments suffers the most strain, like
the pockets and (sometimes) the zipper (hey-oh!).
The idea to use metal rivets to reinforce
the stitching of work trousers is the brainchild
of one, Jacob Davis, a native Latvian who
lived in Nevada as a salesmen during the 19th
century.
Davis earned his keep selling clothing and
general supplies to the many miners and workers
who called the area their home.
The legend goes that the wife of a miner (some
sources say a woodsman) came to Davis lamenting
the fact that he often tore the pockets off
of his work trousers and implored him to find
a way to strengthen them.
The legend continues that Davis drew inspiration
from a horse’s saddle in his shop and hatched
the ingenious idea to reinforce the pockets
and other areas with metal rivets.
Annoyingly, the exact details surrounding
the invention of the first pair of jeans as
we’d understand them today will likely never
be known, so we’re just left with the aforementioned
legend.
But it, at the least, seems plausible enough
that Davis probably got the idea from a customer
or customers who were having problems with
torn pants, so he came up with a solution.
What we do know for sure though is that Davis’
“riveted work pants” were a huge hit with
locals and that it only took a short while
for demand to greatly outstrip the already
meagre supply.
Realising that he’d stumbled upon a goldmine
potentially more lucrative than the actual
goldmines his customers were working in, Davis
understandably became very paranoid about
someone stealing his idea and he sought to
patent it.
However, despite his short-term success, he
simply didn’t have the scratch to do it
himself, a whole $68 (about $1300 today).
So, he reached out to the man whose name would
eventually become synonymous with the product,
Levi Strauss.
Strauss, similar to Davis, was a native European
(originally hailing from Bavaria) who’d
travelled to the states to try and make his
fortune.
The pair became acquaintances through Strauss’
dry goods store, which supplied Davis with
the material he needed to make his riveted
pants, among other product.
After a brief and poorly spelled letter exchange
(“The secratt of them Pents is the Rivits
that I put in those Pockots…
I cannot make them up fast enough…My nabors
are getting yealouse of these success…”),
the two men met and, with Strauss’ money,
they were able to successfully apply for a
patent on their riveted pants in 1873.
That same year the pair began producing the
pants on a mass scale.
Curiously, when the pair first began producing
jeans, they sold two varieties, the blue denim
kind you could find on the shelf of any clothing
store today and a pair made from a fabric
not dissimilar from canvas, known as “duck
cotton” (often also used by Davis for making
tents and wagon covers).
The former proved to be wildly more popular
than the latter and soon became the only kind
the company sold.
The reason denim proved to be so much more
popular than duck cotton is twofold.
Firstly, denim becomes softer as it ages (unlike
duck cotton that will pretty much always feel
like you’re wearing a wagon cover), an attractive
quality in a piece of clothing you’re expected
to wear every day.
And secondly, because it looked better.
Denim jeans were originally dyed blue partially
because indigo dye was cheap and readily available
in large quantities in America, but also because
the dye was dark enough to easily hide stains.
Further, the dye in the small quantity needed
per jean, combined with the weave of denim,
wouldn’t seep through the denim to the other
side.
This meant the risk of the dye staining your
legs is effectively nil, which is again, a
desirable quality in a piece of clothing you’re
going to be getting sweaty in on a daily basis.
The fact that the dye only stains the outside
of denim jeans also means that as they age,
they gradually fade as the dye is inevitably
worn away.
This proved to be another highly desirable
quality of the garments that’s still popular
today, with many even preferring to buy pre-faded
versions.
So how did the world of riveted pants go from
being the exclusive domain of the cowboy to
the go-to fashion for everyone from sweaty
hipsters to cool grandparents?
Well, that’s down to a multitude of factors.
The first, and probably biggest thing to happen
to the world of riveted pants was the expiration
of Levi’s patent in 1908, which gave dozens
of imitators a chance to flood the market
with knock-offs.
The second thing was likely the romanization
of the “cowboy lifestyle”.
While the deeply entrenched association with
manual laborers and rural people initially
turned more affluent people off of the idea
of wearing denim jeans, as time passed, the
allure of wearing something so quintessentially
American began to take hold, culminating in
the “dude ranch craze” of the 1930s with
people paying money to experience the “traditional”
cowboy lifestyle, jeans and all.
A third thing that helped denim jeans become
popular, particularly overseas, was their
popularity with servicemen in the 1940s and
1950s, who often liked to wear them when they
were off duty.
A fourth thing that made the garment popular
with the younger generation was the release
of films like Rebel Without a Cause and The
Wild One, in which the protagonists wore jeans
as a way of rebelling against societal expectations.
After the release of these films in the 1950s,
demand for jeans exploded amongst like-minded
youths.
This demand continued through the 1960s and
1970s where jeans were picked up by almost
every youth counter-culture movement that
sprung up.
In the 1980s, interest in jeans went nuclear
with the release of a series of sexually charged,
strong armed ads like the infamous Brook Shields
Calvin Klein ads or the decidedly more tame
“laundrette ad” which saw sales
of Levi’s increase by 800% in the UK.